DIFFERENCE IN PLAYOFF EXPERIENCH
BOY, ANDREW ENOUGH
SCORING WITH THEIR BIG LINEUP
THOMPSON HAD NOT PLAYED TOGETHE!
AND FINISHES.
>> Jones: AL HORFORD IN HIS
FIRST FINALS KNOCKSes: HORFORD
THREE.N THE BAY
AREA, WHERE HE WENT TO COLLEGE
AT CAL-BERKELEY.
HE'S ON THE BEEN OUT WITH A NEC
FORMCIPIENTS, VISIT CURRY. PORT
THE JUMP
WHITE HAD A NOTION OVER TO ORNE
LOVE,
OPPOSED.
THAT'S HIS SECOND.
HE SAID, WE PLAYED WITHWN THE
FREE THROW.SHER.
IT COMPLETES THEM OFFENSIVELY,
THE THINGS HE'S BRINGING TO THE
TABLE AS OF N WHY THEY'RE
PLAYING IN JUNE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE IS AT HOME.
HORFORD. STEPH CURRY GO ABOUT
PORTER WITH AN OPEN LOOK.
SECOND AND A HALF DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SHOT AND GAME CLOCK,
S T
OF HANDS AS ANYONE IN THIS
>> Jones: WIGGINS GETTING READY
TO COME WITH KLAY AND
STEPH AND DRAYMOND.
NOW HE'S DOUBLE-TEAM.
>> Jones: IGUODALA, AROUND THE
WORLD, GREEN -- GOT IT.
BROWN WORKING AGAINST KLAY
THOME'S BROWN AGAINST PORTER.
WHITE ON THE DRIVE.
>> Jones: GOLDEN STATE HASN'T
SCORED IN THE LAST FOUR